the us is launching airstrikes right now
in northern iraq in response to the
militant group isis which has been
controlling
parts of northern iraq for months now
president obama who would work so hard
to pull the us out of iraq
authorized airstrikes against isis if it
threatens herbal
which is the capital of the kurdish
region in the north or if it threatens
mount sinjar where
thousands of an ethnic religious
minority called the yazidi are hiding
out from isis and this seems like a
really good thing
for the iraqis who are behind obama's
red line around the curtis region but
the thing is is that most iraqis are not
behind that red line most iraqis
in northern iraq have been living under
isis rule for two months there's no sign
that president obama's airstrikes are
going to push isis back from there
so why did obama do this why did he draw
a red line that just protects a tiny
sliver of the country and not the rest
of the country that has
already been conquered by this awful
group well the first reason
is that the kurdish region in northern
iraq is
semi-autonomous it has a stable
government of its own
has a strong military that has been
pretty good at keeping out
isis forces there are a number of
americans based there but the iraqi
government based in baghdad
is a complete mess the military deserted
on mass when isis invaded
the civilian government has been on the
verge of collapse for months
america does not like the prime minister
very much who they think has been making
the crisis worse
so obama's calculation which is cold but
probably correct is that he can save the
curtis region in the north but there's
probably nothing he can do
for the rest of iraq good news for some
iraqis but for the many millions who
have spent the last few months
under rule by isis there's no end in
sight